Motz ah Wow keeping it highbrow I like
it Mozart Mozart is a good suggestion to
start us off this quarter here breakfast
I mean technically it's not a food is it
so
okay breakfast breakfast and Mouser you
found a loophole in the rules there I
like that
don't be one of those guys that goes
insect they're technically not an animal
because I don't care
back quadrant over there what you guys
gonna suggest yes I mean again some
people is a food in it there's a guy
earwax breakfast bowtie yeah obviously
I'm not these people back quadrant over
this side yeah okay and I feel like you
guys have been quiet here what do you
guys want to show there were two at the
same time there was a British man laying
the side down by saying cunnilingus you
are British on you mate yeah we're from
yeah whereabouts but I'm not American I
know Burroughs you know if you say
Hackney I'm not gonna go at you because
you'll probably murder me but if you're
like oh Richmond upon Thames I'll be
like I'll bloody have you wear Bullock
we're worthy we're their wallet Arsenal
is near then there you can see we're
practically best mates already uh-huh so
you said cunnilingus now someone else
says something at the same time I'm
gonna see what they said and hope it's
better what was the other person that
said something country music I mean it's
all gosh there's a connection there
okay we'll try and find a way to chart a
course around those two suggestions
while keeping it PG so we have Mozart
we have cunnilingus in country music we
we have breakfast we have earwax what's
our final one we had nuclear reactors
this then lovely people the comedy &
magic clubs give me a little thing for
you guys very special thing called for
one person over there already getting
excited I think you know what's
happening now a little thing called a
freestyle rap that is a rap made up on
the spot based entirely on no
suggestions suggestions nuclear related
reactor cunnilingus and country music
breakfast earwax
mosa and entirely made up on the spot
never scripted never to be seen again
and do not worry it would not be
anywhere near as atrociously bad as
you're expecting a twenty nine-year-old
privately educated middle-class white
boy to be let's roll that be
that's a shall we do you can crank it as
well this is a track I've not floated on
before sent me by a guy in Berlin so
we'll see how it goes you guys seem very
unconvinced yo the beef floors watch the
guy attack I got a long fingernail I'm
digging out the earwax cerumen that's
the technical term my sister went to
medical school so you know that I learn
I like to pick it out and roll it up
into a sphere you're gonna keep it there
don't impact that in wax in your ear
otherwise you gotta get it syringe by
your nurse or GP I hate the smell era
sniffing I go pee weed how does it smell
so bad wipe it on my clothes I do it
also with the bogey get from up my nose
he for one thing yeah you must take care
keep the earwax in all the delicate
hairs and ever needed for hearing yes I
learn again there were classical
composers like Beethoven he was deaf
couldn't hear for decades of his life
but then most I came along people like
was this kid like he's just five years
old and so simple
at the piano composing the symphonies I
will say yeah and the day is he the real
master Amadeus wolf can expand like long
pasture what a weird simile I'm dropping
in there I'm living in Vienna in Austria
yes I don't care that he has weird hair
very long
it never scares me I don't hate him like
my name Salieri
are you aware I've got a feast for the
eyes the Far East in Japan they were
surprised when there was an earthquake
Oh weird we all got choir when I bring
up Fukushima a nuclear disaster at the
nuclear reactor they try to clean it up
they tried to dredge it with some
tractors but all the water supplies are
infected it's like Chernobyl this the
poisonous invective is used by the media
they stare and they flower and say we
should get rid of nuclear power no
technically it's the last hope we've got
all the greenpeace people down here and
Hollander the caller say you know use
the wind use the solar and the sea yes
is the right thing but I don't know calm
down posthaste
as long as we accurately dispose of
nuclear waste maybe put it in the sea
that is such a thriller if we grow a
tiny lizard to a massive Godzilla and
he's riding around on top of us he
brushes New Yorkers as I eat you for
breakfast plan you like a pancake mister
real
I like the back one pick not bacon I use
the maple syrup put it on a tall stack
if you give me your shirt I'll be like
what's that I want to eat so many
pancakes I use all the flour and all the
eggs and the milk it's in my power to
know all the ingredients you could find
there I also know the breakfast lingo
from the diners one leg off a pair of
pants that means coffee I've learned
that when I work in the front there was
American guy sitting there in the bar
and he said arm from the sound can't do
the accent well doesn't matter though
I've got the accent our music he was
from the south so I knew that he's
loving country music he was jamming
along well his steps and hats he was
saying Billy Ray Cyrus erupts that loved
him but I hate his daughter she makes me
sad not smiling she doesn't do that
genre
her name's Miley the last thing that we
must discuss I'm getting embarrassed red
in the face cunnilingus that wasn't
meant to be any type of pun but we'll
Edwards is gonna get room
[Applause]